Das ist wirklich ein irrer plan ein chinesisches forschungs ziehen will einen erdnahen asteroiden
einfangen und ihn sicher zur erde bringen das soll mit raumschiffen oder einem schwarm von sonnen gelingen schon im jahr
2034 könnte so ein brocken von 6,4 meter durchmesser
kontrolliert auf unbewohntem gebiet niedergehen und somit das leben auf der erde vor schlimmerem bewahrt werden vor einer
befürchteten kollision nämlich wie die astro jeden fall technologie konkret aussieht und ob die pläne tatsächlich
realistisch sind das erfahrt ihr jetzt bei klick zum science fiction herzlich willkommen
Einen möglichen kandidaten für den krassen plan eines chinesischen
forschungsteams gibt es schon ein asteroid der sich noch in etwa 100 millionen kilometern entfernung von der erde befindet sein gewicht
mehrere hundert tonnen bis 2029 will man ein mögliches van konzept ausgetüftelt haben und so könnte man den asteroiden schon
2034 sicher zur erde bringen aber von vorne auch wenn es nach science fiction klingt das konzept stammt aus einem chinesischen
ideenwettbewerb in shenzen hier sollen forschungsteams motiviert werden außergewöhnliche und bahnbrechende konzepte zu entwickeln
dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
Ja es klingt wie science-fiction jedoch glaube ich dass es umgesetzt werden kann die idee hat das mit 59
weiteren konzepten jedenfalls ins finale geschafft einer chinesischen nachrichtenagentur zufolge
tüfteln wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler des jan 14 laboratories of space technology
schon an der konkreten technischen umsetzung für den asteroiden gefahren die
entwicklung von schlüssel konzepten sei hier noch dringend notwendig sagt das forschungsteam selbst zudem sei auch die suche nach
geeigneten kandidaten keinesfalls bereits abgeschlossen die idee sieht vor
raumschiffe oder sonden in richtung des aktiven zu schicken diese könnten eine art über große tasche im schlepptau haben die den
asteroiden einhüllt und seine geschwindigkeit
drosselt so könnte er dann stück für stück in richtung erde gezogen werden dem konzept zufolge würde dann ein bereits
entwickeltes hitzeschild seine eintrittsgeschwindigkeit weiter reduzieren so würde er in die im fall den sturz auf die erde
überstehen und eben nicht verglühen dafür müsste seine geschwindigkeit nach angaben der chinesischen nachrichtenagentur
von 1200 kilometern pro sekunde auf etwa 140 meter die sekunde
gesenkt werden der kontrollierte absturz sollte zudem natürlich in einem unbewohnten gebiet passieren dieser schritt würde wohl mit
zu den größten herausforderungen überhaupt gehören denn der asteroid dürfte keinesfalls außer kontrolle geraten sobald er in die erdatmosphäre
gelangt ist das ziel der mission sei es objekte die der erde gefährlich werden könnten aus dem weltall zu beseitigen man wolle aber die so
eingefangene asteroiden auch genauer erforschen und so hinweise auf die entstehung unseres sonnensystems
erhalten zudem könnte man sich auch die ressourcen
die er für ihnen enthalten zunutze machen metalle und mineralien die auf der erde nur selten zu finden sind bislang
wurden missionen zu asteroiden als reine
forschungsansätze durchgeführt die nasa beispielsweise hat raum fahrzeuge auf einem asteroiden
gelandet eine japanische sonde hat auch partikel mit zur erde gebracht
aktuell ist die japanische aktuellen mission hayabusa 2 am start die sich derzeit im orbit um den us open ein 6 2
17.30 uhr
befindet und später dort auch mal länder absetzen soll doch der plan der chinesen ist größer dazu liebt im gegensatz zur mission die proben
zurückbringen wollen wir einen ganzen asteroiden mit mehreren hundert tonnen gewicht zurückbringen lassen
der eine potenzielle bedrohung für die erde darstellt und dessen ressourcen wir dann nutzen könnten die nasa hatte seit
2014 übrigens an einem ähnlichen konzept gearbeitet hier wollte man
potenziell gefährliche hast du ihn jedoch nicht landen sondern in eine stabile umlaufbahn um den mond bringen die
us-raumfahrtbehörde hatte diesen plan im letzten jahr dann aber
gecancelt wenn ihr kein video verpassen wollen auch extra videos und livestreams nicht dann werdet mitglied hier auf dem kanal
und nimmt auch noch ein paar privilegien mit außerdem unterstützen wir uns mit einem kleinen betrag
einfach auf mitglied werden hier unter dem video klicken und vielen dank an die schon dabei sind das macht uns etwas
unabhängiger von den schwankenden werbeeinnahmen hier auf youtube wenn ihr immer garantie über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollte dann hättet mich bei whatsapp
darum geht ihr die etwas unzulässige abo box hier auf youtube und ihr verpasst kein video mehr
einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal tricks um social and media
abonnieren dafür einfach hier klicken und aber nicht auf keinen fall nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen wie geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
gefährlichste hast du in etwa nasa rammbock gegen ben you bis dann bleibt dran
fast vergessen